so thank you Richard for inviting me
today we focus on startup investment on
energy and environment for China market
China has 1.3 billion population that is
21 percent of world population however
China has only 7% of world fresh water
supplies and consume 22% of world energy
68 percent of the energy produced in
China came from coal it's the oldest and
dirtiest energy these coal-fired power
plant emissions contain toxic element
like sulfide dioxide nitrous oxide
particulate matters hydrogen chloride
hydrogen fluoride arsenic and heavy
metals like chromium cadmium and Mercury
coal plants are the major source of
carbon dioxide emission the primary
cause of global warming shortage will
affect world food supply and pricing
suddenly 20% of our air pollutants come
from China in 2014 the state guidelines
from China suggest it was soon producing
less grain that it consumes food
shortage is a huge problem in China
China is losing arable lands major costs
a land pollution water pollution and air
pollution China government has revealed
3.3 million hectares of lands as large
as Belgium is too polluted to grow crops
no planning is allowed in certain areas
to prevent toxic food from entering the
supply chain high level of cane el
camión a metal harmful to living bones
were found in contaminated rice 20
percent of China's soil is contaminated
water pollution many rivers are severe
polluted by industry parasites and
fertilizers so many rivers are severe
polluted by Industry pesticides and
fertilizer water resources are becoming
scared because of the climate change and
usage by large coal-fired power stations
ten months ago I personally experienced
the worst air pollution in Beijing
Beijing received the highest fred alert
days before Christmas Day I look out the
glass window inside the airport it was
thought gray I couldn't see the sky
nearly 300 cities in China suffer severe
air pollution caused by traffic and coal
emission causes respiratory diseases
more than 1.6 million people die each
year from breathing toxic air air
pollution caused China 11 trillion
dollars in economy on productivity loss
in factories shutting down on bad air
days and flight cancellations
sick days and hospital visit linked to
serious chronic illness like heart
disease and lung cancer in a factor ism
and outdoor recreation energy crisis
China only has enough proven coal
reserve a reliable energy source to last
another 28 years to put it in
perspective the world has a hundred 11
years of proven coal reserve and USA has
264 years of coal reserve China is also
running out of energy all these major
problems are becoming opportunities for
investment according to China five years
plan China is aggressively investing in
smash city from smart factory to smart
farm from smart energy to smart building
with rapidly dropping prices on
internet-of-things the smart city will
be relying on the uprising demand of
industrial IOT in areas of smart grid
transportation logistic water waste
management environmental sensors
I believe energy saving can be achieved
by upgrading existing buildings and
creating smart buildings about 40% of US
energy consumption was consumed in
residential and commercial buildings
heating's ventilations cooling lighting
in manufacturing facilities ai machine
learning robotics drones and bio
engineering will find its way in solving
food stop shortage in agriculture tech
investment
China will Chrome cows boyalife group a
joint venture invests 42 million to open
a new factory to crawl up to 1 million
head of cattle each year by 2020
China faced huge problems in energy
crisis food shortage and pollution if
the world witness the success of London
in clearing their air pollution in 1950
and u.s. in cleaning up our la air
pollution in 1960 there is hope for
China today we have invited to start of
CEO who are changing the world by
disrupting the solar energy storage and
LED lighting for buildings there is hope
for the world ok so that's why while
we're moving on to the next set of
slides I got a follow-up question for
you are you how did you select these two
companies how did you find the companies
how did you are what's your connection
so I have been investing the last 18
months in green technology building and
talking to various business industry in
ciders party involved and trying to
understand you know what are the
barriers to prevent us from moving to
smash city and smart buildings and these
you know many months I have been looking
at industrial IOT IOT that applied for
commercial buildings and I do believe
that in order to move the whole world
into smart city you have to make the
building smart so that leads to me
reconnecting with Shawn's and learned
that you know he was running a company
on solar energy storage startup in Utah
and then I also run into Henry about one
or two months ago and you know little
Don I know that you know he's working on
smart lighting so I'm meeting with
dozens and dozens of startups that are
in various stage in investing in small
city and smart buildings ok well I
really appreciate the introductions and
let's move ahead and ask John if you
would give us some prepared calm down
sure first of all thank you Richard or
doctor Dasher for inviting me and best
for inviting me as well we're excited to
share about our what we're doing I'm the
CEO of energy solar Shawn Glen grass and
the mission of an end goal of energy
Soler's to bring the world affordable
solar power or affordable renewable
power there's a lot of companies in the
world that are trying to address or
solve this problem we've discovered or
we've kind of kind of noticed that many
of these solutions are from a top-down
perspective meaning that it's
governmental organizations governments
large large organizations are trying to
build very large projects we're actually
solving the problem we're addressing a
problem from a different perspective it
is from a bottoms up and that's what I'd
like to talk to you about is how we're
trying to solve or address and promote
renewable power
through consumer products are from the
grounds up just a little bit of
background of myself just a little bit
of experience in China I've actually
lived in in China for several years my
first startup I did was actually a
BlackBerry app for Chinese translation
in China so hindsight 2020 I wish I
would have decided to do on iOS but I
chose the wrong horse
so BlackBerry's is pretty much yeah it's
not doing too well I actually came back
to the US and then started working for
Apple and then actually went to China
with Apple to expand the Apple stores so
I had a little bit experience in
Shanghai and then actually I left Apple
to join a Sequoia vak startup called
Robi and I was the VP in the company and
was the general manager for the Greater
China region and so I was based out of
Shanghai and traveled throughout Greater
China basically in in the software
industry I then actually came back to
the US and joined another startup is a
kleiner back startup arrow hype networks
but our R&D and development headquarters
was in Hangzhou in south of Shanghai so
again made many trips to Hangzhou and so
I have a lot of experience in China and
best was talking about her her Christmas
in Beijing I lived in Shanghai for over
two years and I have children that went
to school and there were days would be
they would have red alerts where the
kids were not allowed to go outside or
we they recommended that we don't take
them to school and things like that so
it is a serious problem I still have
friends who still live in China and so
again through these renewable power
solutions we can solve this problem and
I think the approach we're taking again
is from a bottoms up so the first
solution I want to actually talk about
that the company recently launched was
our Kodiak portable solar generator and
you can see here I don't even know you
notice the first picture was the truck
and on the bottom there's some solar
panels and a little black box that
little black box can store 1.1 kilowatt
hours of power
and so when you stand you store it from
multiple ways but once it's stored you
can actually apply it or use it in many
different ways
mostly for emergency preparedness or
outdoor recreational when you don't have
access to the grid now in the u.s. this
is the use case is that people go out
and and actually choose not to be
attached to the grid in developing
countries there is no choice you
actually live in an environment where
there is no grid and so this solution
can be used to help them have access to
power to charge their mobile devices or
their appliances and so forth
the Kodiak generator is powerful enough
to actually run a refrigerator for
several days without being recharged now
if you recharge it every day then you
can actually use power your refrigerator
your washer or whatever devices
basically in perpetuity I mean as long
as the Sun shines you have power and if
the Sun doesn't shine then I think we
have bigger problems than that so so
again the use cases let as I said are in
camping hunting in even in the office
and actually an RV again when you apply
this into the developing countries an RV
could actually be someone's home office
is you know home an office is also can
you can use but camping hunting in there
are many people that actually living
outside in the wilderness or in the in
in the undeveloped areas and that's
where you would use these solutions and
you charge it like I said using solar
panels or charge it using the wall
outlet or charge it using other means
like a cigarette lighter in your car
it's when you're driving you can charge
the generator so a little bit about the
company we've actually were we're a
spinoff from a retail and commercial
solar company in 2012 and in 2015 when
we actually got serious we incorporated
and actually started energy solar and so
we've we've actually again the
trajectory here is we started getting a
little bit of success but it's only in
2015 that we got really serious and so
this year we expect to sell over 2
million dollars again we're early
stage startup consumer products but
that's that's what we're doing so we're
actually working on a next-generation
generator that is a six kilowatt system
that is intended to run your whole home
thus the smaller generator which I
showed earlier is actually one kilowatt
and you cannot really run your home on
that you cannot run your air
conditioning or you cannot run your
clothes dryer but a six kilowatt system
will run the whole thing and with
portable solar panels which we also
develop you can actually put your panels
on your balcony and so that means that
you don't need a roof to have panels on
top again there's there's a there they
call it the rooftop revolution right
which is the solar revolution and so in
the US where for most familiar with the
u.s. in the US and actually in many
parts of the world I'll talk about China
in a second but in the u.s.
participating in the rooftop revolution
implies that you actually own your roof
if you don't own your roof you can't put
solar panels on top what about you know
what if you live in an apartment or a
high-rise or you're renting there's
about 50 percent of the market in the
u.s. does not have access to solar now
you actually look at China I was just
there recently on a trip you have high
rises and high rises you know as far as
you can see where they're gonna put
their solar panels so our solution we
feel is very well positioned to address
this market where you can put your solar
panels on your balcony and have your
generator inside and charge it during
the day and as much power as you can
capture from the Sun you can use it at
night to offset your electricity bill so
again our next-generation generator will
use advanced technologies that will make
it lighter and more portable and more
powerful than other products out there
we actually expect or aim to go after
the the tesla powerwall solution and we
we feel that our solution is superior
because it's actually not tied to the
wall you can actually take it with you
if you need to we also have other
products that are small
you'll see here there's a little
foldable solar panel battery bank and so
that we're actually building that and
are about to launch this product into
the market and this product is actually
can be sold worldwide there's a bigger
version which is so they actually they
the the smallest one is a six thousand
milliamp battery bank with a three and a
half watt solar panel so you can
actually charge it in one day and after
you charge it you can charge your iPhone
multiple times or other devices and so
this larger one actually can charge it
many more times so but these solutions
can be deployed in any market and if I
guess just doing a little bit of a back
of the envelope math you know on a
weekly basis you you know the standard
user will use somewhere between 30 to 50
depending on how big the phone is if you
have the big phablet or the big thing it
takes a bigger battery but it on average
you're using about 30 to 40 watt hours
per week to charge your phone if you and
that equates to about you know 1800 watt
hours a year and if you multiply that by
the 1.2 billion cell phones in China if
you get to get and just thought exercise
if you got everybody in China to use a
portable solar battery bank to charge
your cell phones instead of charging it
in the wall you'd actually be saving
like 2 terra watts which is 2246
gigawatts and that can power about 1900
US homes by just using a solar-powered
battery bank and so again to summarize
our approach to solving this problems is
actually from the bottoms up not from
the top down the top down takes a little
bit longer you need to work with
governments and large organizations and
that takes a long time I think the the
analogy to this is is in Africa for
example the the landline phones it takes
the government forever to put in a
landline phone and so the market
basically moved beyond the government
and started adopting cell phones and so
the companies just put in a cell tower
and everybody just bought cell phones
even though there is no grid to charge
the cell phones
so that's we expect to actually address
this problem using consumer products and
go from a bottoms up okay so Shawn as
I'm getting Henry's slides ready I want
to ask you a follow-up question so these
are usable in any market yes did you
start to sell in the US already the
revenues you showed or those premises
you primary us yes and so now you're
starting to go in - yes yes okay next
question is interior versus East Coast
cities for the smaller pack the one
point one kill yes that seems like it
would be made for places in the interior
of China where there's not a good grid
right right it actually the so I think
you're very kind of a you know very good
perception that that it is actually a
very good use case for the interior
where the grid is not as established but
we feel that I was actually in Shanghai
where one of the typhoons hip and the
grid goes down so what do you do
no one has power where do you get power
that's if you care about you know the
quality of life your your communications
and so forth everybody can use this I
think it's especially appropriate in the
interior where the grid is not as
established again but it's also true
that people who have the money to buy
products like this are yes in the
coastal yes yes yes so okay thank you
very much we'll come back and talk more
about this when we get to the Q&A for
now I've got Henry I've got your slides
up are you looking at your slide are you
looking at my face my nice line
I may need to ask you to go to which
page okay I think that would be great
I'm on your time we can stop okay we're
ready okay good good afternoon everybody
thanks for asking me to join you it's a
pleasure I want to explain the
thinking's behind
the light project which was a very long
complete time slot we started being bits
and pieces of it in 2003 as many years
ago we started out trying to address
what we think are the issues that will
be facing the LED lighting industry and
it's a very tiny team we are overly
aggressive and try to address many
different things now which one we all
think should be done but first of all I
have noticed that the LED lighting has
been will be around from the time we
start but they it takes all kinds of
different drivers because everybody
makes power supplies that is the
different voltage different current and
because LED needs a current limiting
driver so if you look at the driver many
veterans there's a whole painful of
drivers that you have to match together
with within and we don't think that
should be the case so we made a
universal driver they can go take
practically 99.5% of the time any LED
light whatever voltage whatever current
and this thing will intelligently knows
how to match the LED with the driver the
same driver you can imply Henry just to
clarify you're talking about the driver
of the circuit to attach the actual
photonic device to the power system
right when you say driver no when I say
LED lights are actually taking energy
from the grid
okay okay but it takes normally if we
put in a light bulb
whether is 25 watt
100-watt the same stocking you can you
can screw in the same different light
pop and the all light up with different
degrees okay t-that's not the case
tell you need that is always they drive
it behind every LED so you need to
something different so that is one thing
that we try to cure we actually see a
everybody mentioned if that's enough
pollution Iran and China has his hands
full with various various pollutions and
health problems to echo that the other
two speakers I was rendered in the
Beijing Airport for two days of st.
Albans imagine the largest airport in
the country was shut down for two days I
mean that that's absolute chaos not not
just chaos and I finally try to help my
own way by picking the area that I know
a little bit about I started setups
lighting venture in China so I know a
little about lighting and I see that the
pollution that is coming with the LED
lighting evolution if not revolution
that is enormous seventy billion seven
billion people in the world if each of
them cross await an LED light but each
year you talk about seventy billion and
historically until the lights come to
action I have not seen any significant
or realistic project that eliminated the
electrolytic capacitor inside the LED
lights now people keep talking about
electronic waste electronic waste is
actually most the source from the
electrolytic capacitor
most electronics the plastic case is
okay is no no different than your
plastic cup the printed circuit board is
all fiberglass in the copper traces in
there in concentration couples not good
but in moderation actually when people
grow vegetable whatever you actually
have to mix some into it for it to
balance out so everything is okay except
for the nectar elliptic fluid inside the
kneecap so we started out trying to
eliminate that you actually the
capacitance now after we seen all that
we also see that the LED drivers has a
lot of flickering some of the flickering
is actually be acquired by the
government like in California for
example there is a title 24 rule that
says all the light that you install must
be dimmable now when people try to make
LED dimmable they the quick way to do it
is to make the light plane make it blink
a thousand times any viewer on 45% of
the millisecond in off 55% the human eye
perceived that as 45% dimming but I've
been jumping up and down to say that
that is not good because all these
blinking would have helped problem now
Henry is a small guy nobody listens but
in September 2015 I Triple E have a
stand that coming out P one seven eight
nine that says if you keep those LED
lights blinking chances are that you'll
get people the worst is get this is
either the migraine headache general
tightness in I fatigue in that order all
the photos are not not good health
problems so we have eliminated that by
using the constant current reduction
driver which is
very difficult to do especially when you
also get the symptom eliminate the
actually the capacitor but we have done
it we have installation in Hong Kong we
are ready to we're getting it certified
for ul and we'll sell it in California
that is one of the reason we met best
so I spoke to her and she said sure help
us with that and we also see that while
we are making all those LED lights the
installation cost is prohibitive in
California chances are that the
installation labor cost a lot more than
delighted sir so we try to eliminate
that part
so because LED itself is inherently safe
that is low voltage save the human touch
so we leverage on that characteristic in
may be so that it is a effective hands
only no tool installation and we make it
so that it is actually IOT at the what
we think
IOT three which is the IOT without any
need for central computer so we so so I
match what I learned from Northwestern
and put it in there and get the
reflectance on that part now after we
put it all together since every single
light has a different driver we make it
t mobile which according to title 24 in
California you have to make it dimmable
and all of a sudden next thing we notice
one month ago Hong Kong had a net that
is a building energy code which is
almost a direct copy of title 24 into a
Hong Kong so Hong Kong requires the same
thing also so I have two significant
markets California in a good test market
in Hong Kong that the government
mandates the use of those beaming so
that is what people I tried to do can
you go to the next page for me so just
so you know I just went to page 3 and
now
one page that is titled hard work hard
work against all odds
should I go under it beyond that when it
was just a page - I mean that the page
would then with the heading - okay yeah
this is a page with heading to it okay
the light was started Wow we and pretty
much in Hong Kong as I said at that time
he started I was the only guy funding it
because I'm not sure I have money
monetary return
so I hesitate to take any money
especially from friends and family but
the scope is actually quite quite huge
in terms of attacking the same that
related problem from very different
angles I have a friend who actually is
the head of the power supply portion of
Hilla packet and he said that don't
bother with the no he kept power supply
it cannot be done in theory only in the
left then we spend many years now we
have it in a very stable form and not
only very stable our ripple current and
everything is actually better than the
ones with electrolytic capacitors we
have invented enough things on how to do
the transformer coil form formation we
pretty much eliminate capacitors out of
the equation almost so we put in really
tiny 1000 oh 1000 of the original
capacitor and it will be very stable so
we did all that and because we do not
require electrician license for
installation we cannot have more than
half of the total cost on any project so
can we go to the next page please okay
now since this is a sharing with the
innovation atmosphere in in Hong Kong
and China and like that we have to say
we are very very happy to have started
the lighting in Hong Kong and in the
Pearl River Delta
whatever because with the access to part
and printed circuit boards and all the
gears and tools with all these people
that you can hire by the by the hour by
the day by the week whatever they help
you that makes our project possible and
the Hong Kong government is extremely
supportive the China government various
pieces of Chinese government like the
central government and the Chennai
government they are all very helpful
with us and because of the Hong Kong we
are very active in the Southeast Asia
they actually mixed with the other
governments so we actually get very good
support both morally sometimes
financially and in relationship to help
us by participating in the Hong Kong
Science Park we get invited to this evac
competition which is competition with 19
countries in Asia
unfortunately that they like concept
with all these different areas of
technologies make it so that we won the
smart building championship they do not
have a sector coyotes but we think part
of the reason is that our connections
without a central computer everything is
not only plug-and-play is in the plug in
place since you don't have a computer
plug into everything is plugging into
one another and the plucking together
does not require any particular
information so so the government's the
for us give my startup funds and make
everything so easy I mean your rent is
reduce reduce reduce eventually to
rent-free including your utilities air
conditioning and management fees and
they give you startup funding we still
have not used a lot of sort of funding
and we should think of some way of
making use of it and they introduce you
to possible enjoy investment
we've been outrun angel but for them to
the investor rattly we are still waiting
for them to reply we actually started
our few percent waiting for them can we
go to next page please this is number
four peer and mentor networking now in
Hong Kong signs path it is like
everybody keeps saying that the building
has some fields of the Southern
California or Silicon Valley field in
the building yes except that it is the
high-rise so everybody is relatively gen
to gether especially when you go to
lunch whatever so the first floor
several building is more like a walking
Street everything but that is the way
that you run into people so anytime you
need an expert in it related that you
use but not exactly in your discipline
you're always running those people so so
everybody can you can ask with the other
people to help you and you get your
share of other people asking you to help
them but that is very very conducive to
solving problems especially when you
have a main problem in some of your side
problems like when I asked what
encryption whatever I run into an
encryption expert in there you just have
lunch and a few hours later we get some
good perixx directional help so if you
go to the next slide please
number five hong kong support programs
yeah I practically government supporting
so I only like to take a slight
introduction to it basically Hong Kong
government is so liberal that if you
have a coming product you can walk up to
them and say that I like to try this
they give you fifty percent of what you
need so you have to raise only one-half
of what you actually need and there's no
strings attached you can donate
something back if you want to but
there's not a requirement as long as the
thing is this
Hong Kong and Mainland longer they don't
even care where yourself and if you have
some pattern they have a patent
application grant which pays practically
a hundred percent of the capital cost
you can get a US patent and China happen
if you want to get a US and EU and China
patent the among is slightly not enough
but two out of the three areas is okay
you can do to Hong Kong and us or Hong
Kong and Ziyi that's enough and then
they have this trial budget which is an
allocated budget in a month sitting in
the Hong Kong central government no Hong
Kong the keep the Meiji come back
government of Hong Kong as long as you
can any of the Hong Kong government
Union you can top the police officer
office and your fire station to use your
product that son would pay for a hundred
percent of the trial so those kind of
things in they teach you how to how to
get named Jose they have dedicated
people that is there to help so it's
very confusing can you get the next page
yeah Henry before we go to the next page
that you saw this is only if you locate
in the Science and Technology Park or is
that if you locate anywhere in Hong Kong
anyway okay so is where you can get rent
free if you're located elsewhere chances
are that you still have to pay some rent
maybe the city the fifty percent subsidy
will apply if you neglect to have rental
elsewhere we actually have a factory
outside of the science part because the
Hong Kong science part because of
pollution worry they do not let us do
the factory even though our factories
Celia Lucia okay let's go on now to
number six market trials so with the
Hong Kong government they are also other
organization we are working with the two
largest private charities
to try our things because our thing fits
the I Triple E health healthy lighting
so that you'll be led with energy-saving
without all these health issues so we
work with it and we recently that means
three days ago receive it has report
from Science Park which we try out they
have all these i solving best landfill
for for children to do the homework we
try it and the light light actually
beats them all in terms of having zero
flickering we have lower flickering than
they are soothing them and so we are
talking to the charity that is also
running their fair share of of charities
supported schools so by doing that we
can tell them that we have document that
thing that I Triple E says that this is
good for a 2-foot good for an occupant
and since our light has less bickering
than I soothing light that you can buy
it in so doing it for the whole school
will even throw in 50% this car so we
are trying to work that out but all
these things including our other trial
client we just finished about 10,000
square feet demo which is very
significant not not huge but significant
demo in in the in the center in Hong
Kong they are very patient
they know they realize they are the
first so they expect that they need to
work with you to solve some installation
problem in like that but their mentality
is that if nobody tries then this thing
cannot find that so they have very
patient and they actually paying client
with very good patience to support us
suggest changes and some of their
suggestions are overly fancy but we also
try
try our very best so we change the
office whatever we throw in a guidance
system that they can have visitors walk
through their office without human
accompany my life were actually walked
there that tour group in the office to
show them where to walk
so with that help is quite useful for
everybody can we go to next page number
seven and he Richmond yeah we've-- yeah
we've-- all the encouragement Hong Kong
government realized that Hong Kong is a
small place they encourage innovation
but they realize that Hong Kong is not
going to be as efficient market to
sustain your your innovation so they say
go to the whole world if you want to
sell to China go to the US after Europe
everything go and they also have this
excellent thing that by picking this
traffic insurance you pay one half a
percent of your order and they guarantee
that if the by overseas by at the same
pain they will pay you fifty 90 percent
on your bills first so that your your
company will not run into great
innovation but die-off account
receivable so that is an excellent
program under certain certain certain
circumstances they may even way the 0.5%
for you so after all that Hong Kong is
also an excellent place for IPO with
good PE good access to invest the cash
in the like and banking center is also
very low interest for Hong Kong interest
is similar to the u.s. so people can
actually get loans in the very low
single-digit range so that's my
experience in starting up both from the
technology and from the startup and
rhymin point of view thank you thank you
Henry as I move the slides around and
get
set up for just general discussion I
want to follow through and ask right now
delight is at the really trial stage do
you have general commercial products
already or is it still kind of proof we
have it already and we are working with
certification agencies like underwriter
lab to get out ul listing before we can
sell hot and heavy in the US we are
already started we get some initial
feedback from the pest lab so we may
still need to take a little bit on the
emission we already passed the safety
side so in the month or two we should be
able to be ready to get a ul listing now
how long the processing do people keeps
telling me they may they may take
another two three months for them to
give you the actual you have number so
we are at that stage everything works in
Hong Kong they do not require ul we
tested ourselves internally not in a
certificate for but you know January
that we perform so we are safe to use
and we have in store these the 10,000
square feet demo also okay great
so I have one question for the panel and
then I'm going to turn the computer
around so that Henry can see everybody
in the audience my question so Bess
you're doing investing you've got a
general view for everything Sean you're
working with the us-based startup Henry
you're working with a Hong kong-based
startup I want to ask you about China
the PRC itself what's the hardest thing
about getting into the PRC for your
particular business best what has been
your experience on the investment side
yeah I have been investing in u.s.
dollar and many of them I urge them to
expand outside US because US market
just one market and in order for
start-up to reach certain evaluation and
get funded by VC in series ABC and lay
stage or you know have potentially a
chance to go IPO and they have to go
like gobo they have to go worldwide so
China is a big market it's very
important one so the challenge is some
of the so here you know we are dressing
a lot of the hardware startup because we
are solving energy and my an environment
so these hot where startup if they start
the product in us then not only they
have to make it to work in US market
certifying ul they also have to think
about how it works in China because the
certification it's different than us and
the electrical power requirement the
specification are totally different even
though you know the a green building
standard we accept our lead in the state
China has a free star and the China is
also open for lead but the fact that you
know if you have to make all your
hardware startup product to go into
China then you know there has to start
thinking about like how they can get
approved by local and stay and
nationwide government and meet the
appliances and you know there's like me
a building specification you have to
meet you know so there's something
interesting you point out that its local
state and national yes free levels
because national is one thing but you
also have to know the state and local
city and so there's a lot of things that
you have to consider when you expand to
China and these are the things that I
see our start-up facing okay chunk what
about you what's been the biggest
challenge so just basing off of my
experience of actually
I was with the electronics or
educational toy company in Emeryville
called leapfrog we actually expanded
into China
I was with Apple in the Apple Store
expanded into China and I actually
operated software sales you know b2b
software sales my one one big thing if I
can choose one would be distribution so
in you know I think one of the things
you have to understand about China is
many different markets it's not one in
the u.s. you have one market there's a
Walmart in every state if you get into
Walmart you're set you're getting a
Costco you're pretty much set in China
there is no unifying distribution system
if you want to sell into the inner part
of China
you have to go and set up relationships
and distributions and with the local
state and federal as well and then you
go to northern China again you have to
repeat that process different set of
requirements and so that's that's one of
the big things and so software you know
apps and so forth is a lot easier
because again it's it's no physical
thing you have to move but if you're
actually selling hardware distribution
is one of the one of the big things and
so you have to partner with with
existing distributors or people that
have existing relationships and then you
have to account for that it takes a long
time okay
Henry what's your experience in terms of
the biggest challenge from Hong Kong
moving into mainland okay
let me share a little thing beyond the
stopping from Hong Kong part I have
started Phillips lighting and also the
KFC and Pizza Hut franchise systems in
China the same central government rules
has many different local interpretation
the myth in law is the same but if you
go to 22 provinces you get 22 different
interpretations they say that go here
and do this and do that
do that so you cannot have a
one-size-fits-all thing even for KFC
working in China I mean in the you have
you would very hard to think that the
Texas KFC would behave differently
California KFC but we really need to
have 26 different franchise and local
teams to understand the differences in a
state interpretation to do things work
what deal I have pretty much decided is
that we'll follow the philips Lighting
methodology Phillips only make the
product get is centrally certified but
work with the local distributors in each
city so that you don't have to face the
final nitty-gritty which in terms of
hours were in return of your sales
revenue is not worth it
you may as well let somebody else do it
for you and then out of the all of the
the profit you share a little bit of
them so the light will be taking the
same approach and by taking that kind of
approach we need to address the what
passes the local certification which is
the trip to see the CCC Charlie Charlie
Charlie that is the equivalent of seee
certification in Europe and equipment to
UL plus FCC certification so by doing
that we will be ready for the three
largest market you have an FCC we are
doing for the u.s. we are doing CEF of
Europe and we are doing CCC for China
but chances are that we can only work
with the local distributors if we try to
go into a city and try to sell things
yourself sharing some profit to the
local but good side of it
one should beside us share some problem
with the local you
that thing's all of a sudden go so
smooth because that makes maybe the
classmate or cousins of whoever's in
charge okay that's great
so let's open the floor to audience
questions I'll point the computer at
who's got the question okay and I see
you first
and actually if you would let me ask
everybody keep your questions kind of
short speak up loudly I may have to
repeat the question Henry I'm curious
for the services provided does the Hong
Kong government take any equity in
startups no all of the time they just
want you to they don't even ask you to
sign that you stay in Hong Kong they
just say that as long as it's grown in
Hong Kong so they are very good quote
and corporate citizen of the world
they're supposed to innovation they know
everything is not required on the inter
enterprises of our schemes they have a
voluntary donation that if you say we'll
give that one five percent one percent
or two percent of equity to the
government that is fine but that is not
required all the other grants and patent
applications and everything that I
mentioned they don't even have an avenue
to take your equity even if you want to
give it to the head
they say that why don't you donate to
some charity now out of that they just
recently have a two billion dollar Hong
Kong startup venture fund so if you have
a thing that is not related to one
particular product of your thing but
generally
you can actually go to them approach
them they are just like any other angel
but they are also less restrictive where
you use the money and more liberal on
you take the money and they require
lesser return than a normally angel so
the government is really wanted to
change the dependence from from what I
heard some changes that the dependence
from real estate and banking and try to
get rebalance back to thee in the Asian
and even high-tech factories in Hong
Kong
living in Hong Kong is impossible okay
thank you
next question Richard I do want to add
additional comment on my mind my party
so you mentioned about the challenge
about entering China market so I
mentioned about the hardware but many of
the industrial IOT also needs a cloud
like the software side so the challenges
of us startup will probably go with a
lot of the Amazon AWS but you know AWFS
doesn't really work very well in China I
would say almost you know not possible
because the performance is so poor and
so a lot of the challenges when you have
the cloud infrastructure working in u.s.
then you suddenly you know if you want
to serve the China market and it's so
huge and you have to start working with
the the cloud the vendor that works to
cover the entire China there's only a
few options in China to do that another
you know challenge is well start of
usually don't think about revenue that
yet because they only want to focus on
making the product but in reality on the
hardware you have to start selling and
making revenue because you have
to pay for the production and you need
to your your cash flow spider than
software so revenue is really important
so collecting money it's a totally
different ball game than us you ask we
used to like you know you pay someone
you have 30 days 60 90 days term and we
have--we and people usually are very
good because if in order for us to do
good business you pay so that you can
naturally continue to you know do more
business in us and and you need to
defend your reputation but in China the
whole business operation the way that
you get people to pay you is it's really
difficult like pulling a car to address
you know collecting money is another art
and science in China so tended to follow
that up we talked about the challenges
is there anything happening say right
now last year this year next year or two
that make China particularly interested
in acquiring energy and environment
related new products or technologies or
attracting startups best why don't you
start with that oh yeah
there's tremendous interest in China
government China fund to invest in
technology here because I seen a lot of
the fund so now that's investment here
by a government fund from China but is
the expectation that the startup here
will take the product to China early
early or quickly quickly it certainly
helps because I talk to many a US
startup and they are not open for China
market not until you know they start
getting investment funds from China
government or related and then you know
they will open to like yeah you know
sure you know because you are my
faster and I'll eat your funding so I
will open up to China
okay shaman what about energy is there
anything that makes this year especially
good for John well I think these past
couple of years or PLAs passed a little
bit so first of all the government
released their new I think their 12 year
plan and renewable energy is one of the
big kind of focuses for the Chinese
government so and in China if the
government is behind you or behind a
certain sector there will be a lot of
activity there's another macroeconomic I
guess event that happened or is
happening is the Chinese government is
promoting the relocation of the non city
or the the the in the countryside or you
know non city population move to roll
yeah that's the word to move from the
rural area to the urban areas and so
there are hundreds and hundreds of
high-rises that are empty waiting for
people to come in because that's part of
the plan and what when all these people
come where they're gonna get their power
from and so there is there's a lot of
power needs especially with you know
with peak shaving you know and balancing
of the grid and so forth so there's a
lot of those those conditions that make
it very very good opportunity for it
just to clarify your products are
completely off grid right well it's
actually we can actually be tied to the
grid if you generate excess power you
can actually point it back in yes yes
and the China grid can accept that yes
yeah okay yeah it'll be a we we've
actually for our next generation
generators we're developing an algorithm
or software that we call nano grid
technology but it's it's for smaller
areas it could be in one single building
or several floors of a building or these
type of beings where you can actually
share and pool power but it also allows
you to actually integrate to the to the
utility grid
okay great Henry what's really good
about this year are you trying to get
actively into the mainland right now we
open to that right this moment the Prime
Minister
rika-chan is in southern China next to
Hong Kong doing a celebration of this
innovative push that China has been
doing the line you you just have a
beauty competition problem because when
they say in the innovation they say that
10,000 10,000 startup companies so you
cannot stand now Miss America so we try
was there now via there Hong Kong
government because the light actually
have the potential of doing that we are
we will say six percent of the
electricity use of any city that adopts
the light and we can shave five percent
of the peak load of the grid so we are
we are also helping on from our side the
price of the Sun burns the more air
conditioning they require when order
school and factories of running that is
where the light uses the lowest energy
so so that is the housing now in terms
of what best mentioned account
receivable is a big help in the Hong
Kong government by having that credit
insurance they preach at your customers
and once they accept your point five
percent you know your guarantee to have
these 90 cents on the dollar pay back
from the Hong Kong government in three
months if the cursor if the kind doesn't
play did that takes a big is worried
about away from you there that mean yeah
Henry Yau actually have the fortune of
getting a commendation from the board of
directors of Philips I turned a 83
percent overdue situation when we take
over the joint venture from the China's
partner in two years I turned
and receivable overdue - porn for 7%
with one zero three seven then overdue
more than 30 days I have to take it
offline but I get to be the best
performing JV of a Philips because of
you you actually collect the money so so
your profit is real by by having the
Chinese government behind you yes but
you also need to get their attention
because there's so many I would say I
would not say exactly Fame but but
balance of people that keeps telling you
that we are men whatever we can give you
whatever you want try to try to get
affecting advantage of you so need to be
careful but I want a Hong Kong
government to help us to demonstrate the
actual energy savings we we actually
have major energy saving that we save
twenty thirty percent more more light
out on that same fixture and so on so
okay that's great thanks do we have
another question from the floor okay
hold on just a second
okay back in the back a question for all
three of you do have any fear that your
ideas will be copied by other companies
and what are you doing to protect your
intellectual property I can take it I
can take a step at that soul our first
generation products are actually
manufactured in in China it's a first
generation product but we are working on
the next generation which has a lot more
IP in it so we actually plan to
manufacture those from the manufacture
the motherboard that has the IP
domestically in the US and try to
actually get it made in the USA and then
export now actually there's a there's
actually there's a benefit to that when
you actually sell into the Chinese
market because Henry mentioned there's a
lot of copies or fakes or not real
products when you are made in the USA
and you're legitimately made in the USA
it's actually valued higher your product
is valued higher and and seen as a
better quality product than a domestic
product so importing it you know
exporting it to China is actually a
potentially opportunity and that could
actually help you with with the IP as
well now that doesn't prevent someone
from taking your product and then
backwards engineering it and so that's
that's the kind of you know that that's
the the universal problem that
technology companies have our strategy
and approach is to actually just
constantly innovate and be two or three
steps ahead of wherever the market is
and that's how you stay ahead okay
before we go to Henry I don't want to
ask a follow-up are you worried about
reverse engineering people going through
and reverse engineering your system and
building another system yeah it actually
is happening already we we're it's we're
experiencing that but like I said if
you're constantly introducing you're
ahead of boom yes exactly so that's up
yeah Henry what what are your comments
on copycats okay let me define a
question into like
levels of copying the most moral way of
copying is just parallel engineering
they just think that this is a good
product less engineer something they
start from scratch or everything this
the next level is the reverse engineer
and try to pick up have your thing and
try to figure what that is and put it
together the lowest in quickest is the
blatant just cocky in China like in
sunjin they are actually advertising
that says we will break any circuit
board we will we are expert in
duplicating the circuit box 4040 now we
have our share of worry we do everything
we that normally people do so we
apparently on when the patent process
sometimes when we go to a particular
talk with a potential partner whatever
we may actually we revisit our patent
portfolio and if this one new idea that
we are talking about we will have a
patent lawyer just saw something before
the day that we have the meeting so we
act actually it was more company we are
fortunate we have like like by now
30-some you mentioned happens in
different areas
now that aside our way of avoiding
copies includes the hardware software
cloud and hardware software combination
I'll explain each one to them we have
our own secret trade secret circuits
that we designed and we are actually
leveraging on a Hong Kong science
company which is National Lab
Applied Science and Technology Research
Institute now they are helping us to
make the special integrated circuit chip
for us once you have that on a waiver
that just raises the hurdle for people
who try to copy you because they have to
throw in the order of one or two million
u.s. just to copy the second thing that
we do is that we will put the epoxy on
everything that we do so our hardware is
difficult to take apart and then in
terms of software we actually put in an
encryption encryption chip on our key
hardware so that only us would know what
that encryption is if they clone our
hardware and actually be able to to
clone to break into our code space on
the on the ROM afresh that they knew
would still doesn't work because of the
encryption chip so that is a combination
hardware and software now we actually
have one more level of software
protection that we are putting together
that instead of just having the software
run its function we have our software
occasionally go back to the cloud tend
to into our database to recertify itself
so people who somehow get the things
going we at least we know about this and
so so on and so forth we actually worry
about more on parallel selling because
we chances that it will sell to Malaysia
cheap wedding without the New York so
what if the Malaysian guy just we ship
our thing to New York we have a way of
addressing that on the cloud in our
central database also so we have share
of worry and we did everything we do we
can - okay great we're getting close to
being out of time is there another
question from the audience otherwise
I'll ask one question and we'll
wrap it up the question that I'd like to
ask is all three of you on the panel
have done business back and forth with
China for some time what do you think is
the biggest changes between the
situation now and say the situation five
or ten years ago but I actually see you
know there's a urge and there's great
demand and supply of cash you know
coming into u.s.
I think 10 years ago I see there's a lot
of cash from us VC going to China invest
in China and want to capture the the
growth and the boom and now it's reverse
it's like the money is you know there's
a rich cash a lot of money in China and
they couldn't really get enough growth
and they want to invest in us and bring
the technology to go back and solve you
know some of the domestic problems okay
great Sean I think the most apparent
thing is is actually the physical
development of China when I when I was
there in 2008 versus when I'm you know
went back just maybe about a month ago
it is I mean even as Shanghai it's just
so many new buildings I mean you know
it's it's it's the infrastructure is
there and actually the the interesting
thing is is on the human capital side
it's actually improving what I've
noticed is there's a lot more innovation
or thinking about developing new
technologies versus just flat-out
copying and so I think that's one thing
that that I actually it's a very
promising that there's a lot of
innovation that's actually coming back
to the to the US you know reverse
reverse
localization whatever you call it okay
yeah great Henry yes I think the the
changes that we see is that from my
Phillips
the government have clean up their act
in making a level playing field for
people and I think they succeeded 8090
percent of the required work already now
what is remaining is still me the
citizen especially there's no other
small businesses that that try to get
rich or try to survive by copying other
people that still need to be done some
of the real blatant things I have to
take it offline on the thing but KFC has
been known to have a local government
require them to fires particular fire
extinguisher at 200 times the going
market wage and things like that but I
don't think those things are happening
again now these are more level playing
fields but you need to still need to be
aware of your crazy competitors that
that one copy okay I'd like first of all
the thanks everybody for coming and
please encourage you to stay and have
some refreshments if you're here if you
would please join me in thanking our
panel for a great session
you